[موسيقى]
الجزيره العربيه هي فسيفساء في جغرافيهتها
وفي بيئتها وفي ثقافتها وفي عاداتها وفي
تقاليدها هذه الفسيفساء يجب ان تظهر على
السطح ويجب ان يعرف لسانها بانه يفترض به
ان يستفيد ويستغل هذه الامكانيات لان
يتحجر في فكر معين او في منهج معين او في
القبيل ويتناسى بان اجداده كان لهم دور
كبير حتى الفتره الاسلاميه عندما خرج خرجت
الجحافر الجيوش من هذه المنطقه من هذه
الجزيره انتقلوا الى جميع انحاء العالم
ناشرين هذا الدين الاسلامي منها الجزيره
هذه التي انبثقت دكتور محاضرات
[موسيقى]
انا ارى ان المتحف ومسرح الاثار والمكان
الذي توضع فيه الاثار مما يؤسف له طبعا
بطبيعه الحال انه في سنوات الاخيره تم
الفصل المتاحف عن الاثار وهذا في تصور
الشخصي خطا كبير ارجو اتمنى من المسؤولين
في وزاره الثقافه تدارك لا يعني هذا باننا
نترك المتاحف الاخرى ذات ذات الاخر غير
اثار نتركها ونقول ان ادعي لا بالعكس نحن
نريد ان تكون هيئه المتاحف هيئه المتاحف
مسؤوله مباشره عن كل ما له علاقه كل ما له
ليس له علاقه بالاثار يعني الفنون على
سبيل المثال المحليه همم الفضاء السيارات
وتطورها كل ما كل شيء هذه كنت هي تابعه
لها لكن اثار المتاحه في الاثريه يجب ان
تكون تحت تحت نطاق وتحت مظله الاثار
[موسيقى]